Wow.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 18th,
2015 how's it going?
Ah,
I'm fucking wiped out and wiped out,
you know,
not because I did all these shows here,
not because they put in maximum effort to make sure everybody got their money's
worth patting myself on the back.
Not because of that.
You know why?
Because I'm an asshole and I went out every night until like three,
four,
five o'clock in the fucking morning.
Like I'm still in my twenties,
you know,
every fucking night.
I know.
I always say right before the second show,
I'd be like,
Hey,
Versium,
there's,
um,
it's going to be an early one.
You know,
he's going to be an early one out.
Fuck.
Who's texting me now?
Come on man.
Leave me alone.
Can you just leave me alone?
Um,
every fucking second show,
I would just be like,
Hey,
I'm fucking a,
I'm going to call an early one and verse.
It'd be like,
oh,
I don't do whatever you want to do.
Do whatever you want to do.
Right.
And then I'd be so amped up after the show,
I'd be like,
all right,
let me just have one little heater here backstage.
Right.
Somebody gave us a bottle of fucking Woodford reserve,
whatever the hell it was.
I do a shot and then that was,
it took a sip of the devil,
right?
And then I got the demon in my veins and the devil starts talking,
hey,
why don't you go smoke a cigar?
I,
why don't you go fucking over here?
Why don't you go over there every fucking night?
Every night.
I've been here for 10 days.
I've gone out every single night.
I'm on a fucking bag,
right?
What am I doing?
Last night was the first night I just did my shows and I fucking went home and
Joe Barton,
Huck Rosebowl tailgate ledge,
nick came up from New York to hang and watch the show.
Actually jumped on and did some time on the second show.
And uh,
I got Bart,
nick and Paul Versey staring at me.
Right.
Of course I want to go,
of course I want to go out.
Right.
But do I know last night was the first night I said I can't.
Why?
Because I learned my lessons,
my lesson after fucking nine days in a row of being an absolute shit head.
Now the only reason why I didn't go out again last night was cause oh,
freckles was getting the sniffles.
I caught a cold,
put an asshole,
kind of a fucking asshole goes out until four or five o'clock in the morning
when he's turning 47 the next goddamn month.
Why would I do that?
I'll tell you why.
Cause I'm a moron.
And you know something.
A lot of you guys listening right now,
you might be laughing.
You know,
I'd be going,
yeah,
what are you a fucking idiot?
Now you know what you are,
you're a parent.
And he got kids so you don't have any choice.
I don't have to fucking wake up to anybody.
You know?
You know that shit when you're laying in bed and your fucking kid walks in,
he started dreaming of an obscene phone call and you realize that some Todd,
they're going,
yeah,
you rps that Shit right?
I don't have to deal with that.
I don't have to fucking deal with that.
So something's got to give,
you know,
we can't have all that freedom,
something's got to balance it out.
So area I got a cold and my fucking liver felt like,
so I took a fucking liver shot or something.
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
you know,
the worst part about this cold is,
is um,
I'm sort of fighting it off cause I went and I got eight hours sleep.
You know,
I'm in that line stage.
We just like,
oh,
it's not going to get any worse.
You know,
basically what's going to happen today is the second I exert myself doing
anything like lifting,
lifting,
like a spoonful of raisin bran to my mouth.
That's going to be the tipping point.
You know what I mean?
With the momentum has just changed.
But a cold virus right there and then it's just going to be over.
So I know tonight
I'm going to be sick.
Um,
at which point I'm going to Pout,
which means I'm going to drink and I'm going to smoke with,
to going.
But
he believed that 47,
literally sliding into 50,
and I'm still behaving that with,
it's a very sad thing to everybody and um,
but I have nobody to blame but myself.
Other than that though,
I want to tell you the show's been going great and uh,
and a bunch of friends and family come out and last night on the late show had
none other than,
uh,
the one man thrill ride.
Jimmy Preston came down,
fucking great guy.
Um,
he's shooting the shit with them and he's got some big things coming up,
some big auditions to move up the wrestling ranks.
And I'm telling you,
I called it,
I told you at least a year and a half,
two years ago.
I'm telling you the guy's a fucking star.
Um,
if you haven't seen any of his clips,
I'll try and re,
I always say I'm going to put the videos up,
but I'm scatterbrained by the time I get to the end of this shit.
I forget what I'm going to try to make sure.
If you don't just look up one minute thrill ride.
Um,
he's the fucking best man.
Fucking hilarious.
Does his wrestling promos in his car,
you know,
without a shirt on,
screaming at him.
I'm telling you,
it's been a while since the WWE got somebody really,
really great on the mic.
And,
um,
I think this guy real,
I'm telling you,
I think he's going to,
he's going to get,
he's going to get to the show,
I believe is what they call it.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
Barton it came down last night.
Fucking absolutely destroyed,
destroyed on the second show.
This is what an fucking maniac Barton,
the kiss.
I've never heard Boston crowds grown.
It takes a lot to make a Boston grown and he had like five of them.
So of course me and Virginia fucking crying,
laughing on the side of the stage.
And um,
but you know,
when,
you know those five times when they weren't and they fucking died laughing at
the other hundred jokes,
he uh,
he absolutely killed it.
So tonight is the last night.
The last night.
Oh,
the last night for jokes.
Okay.
Uh,
summer cold makes me feel awful.
Um,
so anyways,
so what am I going to do today?
Am I going to take it easy?
Well you know,
I gotta fucking upload this thing at Starbucks cause my parents have fucking
parent in our net,
which is basically a,
I dunno,
dial up 2.0 my mom always drives me now she's like,
hey we have the internet,
I have the Internet.
It's like yeah you got one of those glow sticks.
You stick on the side of your fucking computer so you have,
you have it,
you have Internet all day long.
I don't fuck it.
Have Internet.
Um,
so then I always have to go up to the Starbucks and I got to stand in the
fucking junkie line.
You know what I mean?
Cause I got to find out what the God damn password is and all that shit.
Plus I always feel like a fucking Mooch,
you know,
I at least always buy a bottle of water and I gotta stay on my immediate to Chai
latte with a fucking presell frazzled,
just sitting and standing in line,
fucking drinks coffee in the middle of the day.
You're a junkie.
Okay.
You want a glass to wake up,
you know,
cause you're not a morning person because you're weak.
Right.
I always love calling people weak.
Like I shouldn't have died years ago,
you know,
and I had my ruptured appendix.
I would've been taken out of the fucking mix.
You know what a dyed sweating under fucking 200 blankets in the 18 hundreds
spinoff.
No,
they had to figure out how to cure that shit in the air.
It is.
Cause they did that.
Now you have to sit there and listen to me every week.
Why do you have to,
you have all the power,
but you're playing the victim once again,
acting as though you can't,
you can't shut it off.
So,
um,
I got to tell you guys,
I'm,
I know I tweeted about this and I can't believe I didn't bring up my last
podcast.
I want to give a shout out to Jessie's customs.
No,
Jesse's custom design.
A airbrush studio that's right here in,
uh,
Boston and I don't want to butcher his last name is Jesse.
Oh,
what the fuck?
We'll give it a try.
Okay,
I see.
Okay.
I Dunno,
it's ACC,
like the college division I a,
c,
a,
n this guy came in one night and handed me one of the sickest things anybody's
ever given me.
Skype,
custom airbrushes,
goalie mask,
motorcycle helmets.
So he came in knowing I'm a Bruins fan.
He went out and bought an official like Nhl level goalie mask and then custom
painted that thing like I was going to be playing golf for the Bruins.
And uh,
on one side of it he had airbrushed a microphone with George Carlin and Richard
Pryor on the other side.
He had the drum stuff,
he had Bonham's sign,
you know,
from the [inaudible] album,
whatever the fuck you call it.
Then he just had the skull part of the skull,
Steven Adler skull from the appetite for destruction,
destruction album with GNR sorta put on and on the back,
you know,
on the one that protects the back of your head.
He had airbrushed,
um,
a picture of Patrice O'Neil from the first benefit poster that Bobby Kelly,
I believe,
to help design.
And then on top he had go fuck yourself.
Um,
and what was great was the fuck was the Ford symbol and a,
I have the Ford f 100.
It was fucking unreal.
Um,
if you'd like to check out some of his work,
uh,
go to,
Jesse's customs signs,
Jesse Customs,
sign.com j e s s,
e s and then custom design.com.
All right.
There's no apostrophe www dot Jesse's custom design.com.
Um,
he does airbrushing pin striping,
gold leaf truck lettering,
motorcycles,
helmets,
and evidently hockey mass.
He's fucking really,
really talented.
And um,
that's something,
I swear to God,
I'll have that thing for the rest of my life.
There's no way I'm getting rid of it ever.
Why would I ever get rid of it?
It's fucking awesome.
So anyways,
back to the podcast there.
Um,
so my world's been very small lately.
I don't know what I mean.
Even going to talk about this week because I've just been fucking drink until
four in the morning.
Oh,
I'll tell you some stories.
Okay.
So I was hanging out with a bunch of high school buddies,
Sachet fucking Saturday,
Saturday night,
right?
Drinking,
having a good time or whatever.
And uh,
we ended up going to leave in the end of the night,
you know,
they turn on the lights and shits,
everybody's going to leave.
And um,
it's funny,
down by the Wilbur theater is like,
there's all these clubs down there.
It's like the meatpacking district in New York,
but like a Boston,
you know,
so it's smaller and cleaner,
you know what I mean?
I'm with smarter sports fans.
Jesus.
So,
um,
we're standing there,
me and two of my buddies in this two comes up asking for change and he's like,
hey man,
you know,
Vaughn on her times mag and you helped me out,
blah blah blah,
blah blah.
So I'd stand there.
Right.
And then two friends digging into their pockets,
you know,
taken out dollar bills and shit.
And I'm looking at the kid,
you know,
he's got fucking this mane of Brown,
shiny hair,
totally conditioned.
He's got a nice pair of glasses on.
He's got this clean ass,
bright orange shirt with a couple of rope.
Next list is around it.
And I just taught,
you know,
I started teasing him.
It's go Jesus to look at yourself,
look at your,
your hair's all condition.
You got to,
you look like you're producing a show with those glasses.
You know,
I've got a couple of necklaces and by then he's already got the money.
So I'm basically in a roundabout way suggest and that he's not that hard.
So he just fucking stares at me.
And then he just holds the money out back to us.
Like he's going to give it back.
Like if you're going to question my integrity as a street person,
I don't think I want this.
Right?
So I reached over and I took it back,
that gave it to my friends.
So now we stand in there and I know he wants the money,
but he's got to keep playing this bluff,
right?
So he starts walking away all sad,
like fucking bill Bixby at the end of the hulk and none of us say anything.
So then he does an about face.
He's like,
come on guys,
I need the money.
You know,
to fuck you fucking,
you know,
I can't help the way I look.
I need the money.
But then as he's saying this,
one of my friends is not looking at him.
He's just staring straight ahead and he says Cisco and do it.
It's over.
Walk away.
Just walk away.
It's as he's yelling over the top,
but I needed money and blah blah.
He's just gone.
It's over,
dude.
It's over.
Just just,
just walk away,
walk away.
So he's making such a fuss.
One of the door guys at the w hotel,
which is right across the street from,
uh,
from the Wilbur comes walking over telling the kid,
he needs to calm down.
You need to calm down.
And kids go,
nick gave me money and then they took a bag of blah,
blah,
blah.
And we're not saying anything.
And as he's yelling,
he's looking over us and it just so happens,
this dude,
no wheelchair comes by,
right?
This homeless guy in a wheelchair,
one of those guys lose legs,
still work.
So He's,
he's walking down the street on his heels,
you know,
walking frontwards,
sitting in a wheelchair.
And my buddy who was going like,
dude,
it's over.
It's over.
Sees the guy in the wheelchair.
And he goes,
there it is.
And he walked over and he gave him the money and my other buddy gave him the
money.
And then the fucking white kid in the orange shirt just flipped out.
You look at our monkey fucking throwing his hands up in the L.
Dot.
Fuck Blah,
blah,
blah.
He stormed across the street
and,
uh,
I got to tell you,
it made my fucking night.
You know,
I don't know,
man.
I'm reverse racist when it comes to fucking beggars.
You know what I mean?
You gotta be pretty fucking filthy.
You know,
as a white person,
you got to look like boxcar Willie.
You know what I mean?
You know?
Got to have like no teeth.
You know,
people,
when people don't have any teeth that constantly chewing,
you got to look like that.
You know,
maybe a stick with a handkerchief and a fucking stale sandwich in there.
Then all day I'll help you out.
All right,
but if you're in your 20s,
come on,
you know my wrong here.
You're fucking white kid.
You're a white guy in your 20s living in the United States of America may swell
bit about this.
You're fucking crushing it,
you know,
crushing it.
Go home.
Call me,
you know,
sell your fucking skateboard,
dude,
I don't,
I don't know what you fucking want from me.
Um,
and let's say,
you know what the word,
if they says homeless vet,
then I do it our rack veteran or something.
Then I give the money.
If it's a white dude,
you know,
so there you go.
People who are pretending to be homeless but not,
or whatever,
you were rebelling against your rich parents.
All you need to do to get me,
it's just putting on a pair of fatigues.
Get them a little bit dirty and then act like you were in Iraq even though you
weren't.
And I'll give you the money.
They get go.
That's how it works.
Someone else probably fucking me.
He just had a douchey face.
It just bugged me.
It just be just,
he looked fine.
It looked fine.
Maybe it was in the beginning of drug addiction is which pounds?
Just throw them out.
So we had all these new clothes.
Um,
I don't fucking know.
I Dunno.
Was that mean?
Was that awful?
Um,
all right.
And other news,
what's going on in the world of nothing matters or whatever the fuck I usually
say the world of absolutely nothing.
So Tom Brady's going to appeal this suspension.
Of course.
By the way,
I want somebody in the,
and the last 40 years and me watching sports,
I want somebody to fucking find something less.
40 years,
a more,
something dumb or they get suspended for four fucking games.
All right,
so the Patriots are going to appeal it.
Obviously the Patriots actually just sat down and wrote a 20,000 word report in
rebuttal to this wells report.
I mean,
how many fucking trees are we going to cut down and chop down over this fucking
horse shit before everybody just admits that schermer say is a fucking baby.
You know what I mean?
So now good Dale,
who's just,
every time he should zig,
he fucking zags.
So Brady's going to appeal it and Roger Goodell is going to be the arbitrator to
fucking choke.
It was a witch hunt from day one and now you got a kangaroo court,
it's fucking hilarious.
You're going to arbitrate the fucking thing that,
that's like a farm fucking showing you and then I'm going to be the judge.
Who Do you think's gonna win?
It's the dumbest shit ever.
I think this is actually going to end up in a real court at which point it will
be laughed out and it'll be over now.
I think they could still could suspend them because the corporations are allowed
to have,
you know,
rules within the rules of society.
So I mean Shit,
take a GE,
they,
they wanted to,
they could say you could never play football again because at the end of the day
it is a corporation that Tom Brady works for.
It's absolute fucking bullshit though.
And what I'm really enjoying is the people that are taking it seriously,
that are really looking at like,
yeah dude,
he is a fucking cheat.
Or like this whole thing is in complete horseshit.
Um,
what's great about it is it's always those mouth breathers moron.
I haven't found one intelligent fan that I have talked to that actually thinks
that this isn't fucking stupid.
You know,
who thinks this is fucking real
people who go to fucking sports bars and I know fans go to sports bars too and I
know that there's the mouth breathing fucking moron demographic of the Patriots
fan base,
but I'm to all those other ones from the 31 other teams because they fucking
hate the patriots.
Those people who go all day,
all day,
you know,
fucking high five and we were in a God damned Jersey with fucking hot wing sauce
all over your fucking goatee.
Those dopes,
those mantated dopes.
They're,
they will forever say that they're fucking cheetahs.
But you know what?
I'm fine with it cause they fucking morons.
But I'll tell you right now,
Tom Brady,
one of the greatest quarterbacks of all time is being fucking railroaded on such
a ridiculous fucking level.
They just ignore and everything.
They're ignoring that they don't have any fucking evidence.
All they have is circumstantial horseshit.
They're ignoring the fact this guy overinflate says,
guy heats up the ball,
quarterbacks from the past that had the fucking jets quarterback came out.
He's fucking going on and on and on about how he used to do that all the fucking
time and that guy sucked.
Didn't make him play any better.
Jesus Christ.
Why don't you fucking,
I dunno,
I,
I know I've been talking about this three times in a row,
but I'll continue to talk about it because I think it's absolute fucking
horseshit.
Obviously.
If he didn't fucking realize it by now that I think it's absolute bullshit.
Um,
so anyways,
with that,
with that fucking half a cunt hair of air out of the ball and that's why you
lost by 38 points.
Really?
That's all I need to do to start throwing strikes when they get out there.
Good fucking Lord.
Good.
Let's like finding somebody in the NBA for cheating because of what?
The level that he wears his socks.
Well,
he had his socks too low.
That's why he hit those fucking 12 three point is to fucking beat us.
Gimme a break Jim,
or say is the biggest fucking baby baby fucking owner ever get that guy a
fucking passive fire.
We laws.
There must be something wrong with the rules.
Somebody change them.
Oh wait,
I sit on the rules committee.
I think I'll change them.
All right,
here we go.
Let's do a couple of reads here for the weaker fuck.
Starting to fucking congested here to get fucked and congested here.
Oh right.
Speaking of sports,
draft kings,
everybody had you heard the new,
I heard it on the new.
Have you heard the news?
draftkings.com crowned its first ever fantasy golf millionaire.
When people play fantasy golf.
This guy won a million bucks doing that.
Jesus help us.
Was the fucking chick who dumped him right before that.
I can't do this anymore.
I mean you're betting on golf.
You're pathetic.
She'll probably take him to court.
I supported him emotionally anyways.
Um,
could you be next everybody draft kings as America's favorite one week fantasy
golf site where you can win huge prizes every week during every tournament.
Just had to draft kings.com before tee off on Thursday.
Pick six golfers,
stay under the salary cap.
And when cash,
oh my God,
whether you're an avid fan of the game or just have a gambling problem,
I just ready to try a new fantasy support.
Draftking lets you experience golf like never before by playing to win a life
changing payday.
These are the biggest one week fantasy golf contest anywhere and only draft
kings.
Kings has them.
You got to admit you don't hear anybody winning a million bucks off a bookie do
you?
So this is pretty good,
but you know,
guys go easier.
Okay,
have fun.
This is supposed to be fun.
All right.
Hundreds of thousands of fantasy sports fans.
Just like you'd discovered draft kings.
Now it's your turn.
Remember to pick your players before tee off on Thursday morning to seriously
cash in by Sunday night.
A Haredi draftkings.com now and use the Promo code defense,
d e f e n s e to play for free and the hundred thousand dollar fantasy golf
contest this Thursday.
First place takes home 10 grand.
Enter defense for free entry now@draftkingsstockcompdraftkings.com that's draft
kings start carb.
All right,
what else do I got here?
Um,
oh,
look at this everybody.
Look who's back.
Old Trunk Club.
All Trunk Club guys,
you might hate shopping,
but you still want to look good,
right?
You still want to look good for the ladies,
you know,
or maybe for the fellows.
You know,
maybe you're a gay guy,
you're one of those gay guys that doesn't know how to dress.
You know,
he's standing there all flustered going down there on a whatever the gay night
that they have,
like they do down at the Wilbur,
one of the nights they have gay night,
right?
Although everybody looked like they could dress that night from what I could
tell,
you know,
and they were very nice to me.
Um,
what if you could snap your fingers,
hey and have a trunk full of clothes that fit perfectly and make you look
amazing.
You're gonna love what gets delivered to your,
to you from Trunk club@trunkclub.com slash bar.
You answer a few simple questions about your look,
your style in your size,
and then they assign a real person who helps to style you.
Well,
you know it Kinda like work boots and flannels.
Uh,
they email you a list of clothes they recommend sending you.
You approve and at no cost to you.
They ship a trunk full of fresh new clothes to your door.
You try them on,
you keep what you want is send back what you don't want in their prepaid prepaid
box that said a better ward road than you could ever pick out yourself in
minutes that I mentioned.
The service free is free,
your stylist,
the shopping,
the box,
even the shipping all 100% free when you go to trunk club.com/burr only played
for the clothes you keep.
No ongoing subscription,
no hidden charges,
no malls,
just great clothes,
handpicked for your style.
All right,
you're going to thank me for this and right now it's completely free.
So get started@trunkclub.com slash bar today.
That's trunk club.com/bar hang on a second.
I got to hit pause.
All right.
It's official.
I got a cold.
God dammit.
You always lie to yourself like you fighting off right now.
I'll take some emergencies that most Cielo cotton in or whatever the fuck is
called.
One drink a big glass Oj.
I put on a wool hat.
Yeah.
Once it got you got,
you want a fucking moron?
Who the fuck does all these shows?
I wasn't taking any vitamins.
It's fucking hilarious.
You know my mom said this morning,
I said,
um,
my mom's like,
hey,
how you doing?
You know?
Hey,
how you doing?
What's going on?
This is,
uh,
the mom morning podcast.
She says,
Hey,
I do.
He said,
I,
you know,
I caught a cold.
I've caught a cold.
You know what she said to me?
She said,
well,
what did you think was gonna Happen?
So that
right there,
it's all you need to know about me.
That's what she said.
Not One of those.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Do you want some fucking Kooky Mooky fucking God coco.
She just fucking gave it to me straight.
What?
What'd you think was going to happen?
The only thing was missing was your fucking dope.
You've been going out till four in the morning every night for fucking 10 days.
What'd you think was going to happen?
She's always been like that and it always bugged me,
but I realized as an adult it really helped me out.
You know,
when I watch other guys walking around,
you know who hadn't like moms that hugged him and shit,
the littlest thing,
they get flustered.
You know,
I'm out of toothpaste,
right?
They tried to marry some woman that's going to be there next mom.
You know,
you got to have one of those moms just got a little bit of ice in our veins
every once in a while,
right?
Like every morning I was a kid.
I had this piece of shit truck,
right?
It was nice,
but I kept it forever because I was smart and I knew that I didn't want to work
for somebody else.
And one of the quickest ways to working for somebody else for the rest of your
life is to buy a new car.
When you're in your 20s,
you know when you can quote,
afford the payment.
I got news for you.
You can't afford the payment if you have a dream.
All right?
Then I had a dream to tell shit jokes for 19 nights in a fucking 10 nights in a
row.
Um,
so anyways,
so my truck wasn't,
wasn't starting all right.
And I fucking called her up from
this little packy store.
I called her up.
I was like,
mom.
I think I was like 19 or 20.
It was like,
mom,
my truck won't start.
I turned the keys,
dude started and I know I got to go here and I,
my truck was terrible,
blah,
blah.
They did the whole fucking hissy fit for a minute and then she just goes,
there was a pause and she just goes,
well,
what would you have me do?
I just want to be like,
oh shit.
All right,
I guess that's right.
She is not a mechanic.
I think I need to get the fuck out the yellow pages and look up a fucking tow
truck.
That's what I had to do.
That's what we had to do back in the day.
Children,
it wasn't all at our fingertips.
You fucking babies with the smart phones.
We're going to take out a fucking,
the yellow pages knowing full well that most likely the page you want had been
torn out,
buy some dope.
That was the thing where I need the number,
I can't remember it,
and they would tear it out
for whatever fucking reason.
Then he had,
you know,
he had to go,
go inside and buy a pack of gum that you didn't even want or a candy bar so you
could have changed for the phone and then you fucking called up.
You know?
Isn't that hilarious?
I'm acting like I worked on a farm.
We had a look of phone number up in a book that was right there next to a phone
and then we had to get a sweet treat to have changed,
to make a phone call.
Hey,
I'll tell you,
it was rough,
you know?
Oh,
fucking far off.
You know,
we've gone from people talking about coming over here and boats to the fucking
depression,
the dust bowl,
world war right to me talking about sitting at a payphone and buying a package,
juicy fruit.
Oh it was really hard.
Um,
anyways,
so where the hell am I?
Um,
I dunno,
I'm going to go to fucking GNC.
I know.
Go talk to some will write it up.
Psychos going to try to tell me did it all naturally.
You've got to get out.
Well you gotta you gotta you getting a cold Bro.
You get a cold.
I got it for here's a giant tub of fucking powder.
Some psychos fucking put together that does not have to go through the FDA.
Why don't you put this through your veins and you know what?
I'm going to do it.
I might as well.
Okay.
Cause I'm hanging out with a bunch of buddies and my tonight that I started out
with,
uh,
you know,
after the shows had done,
um,
I've been having so much fun this week.
Like,
I keep having version dance Smith a guy started out with,
he's been opening for a couple of shows that are verse he wasn't on and um,
okay.
They both been like Dan Smith remembers the rooms that I did.
So I've been telling them,
I go give him my,
my,
you know,
credits set.
They'll know,
you know,
he might've seen him on fucking,
I dunno,
let them in or something like that.
And then the end,
he will say like,
uh,
you might have seen him on Letterman.
You might've seen some of his specials on Netflix or you might've seen him at
the 99 restaurant and Belviq a Massachusetts back in the day.
Um,
no,
that's a good topic.
Anybody here in Massachusetts?
Some of the fucking places I used to work I used to do the 99.
Isn't Bell Rick on a Tuesday night,
John David used to host it.
Um,
I used to go up there,
unknown Patrice rest his soul.
Dane Cook,
Bobby Kelly,
all of us used to go up there every Tuesday the ninth going up to the nines.
Right.
I remember it was in the middle of fucking nowhere to you just drove down this
hill.
It's like they wiped out like 6,000 trees to put this fucking thing up.
And a,
I used to work that one.
The comedy vault,
the Dick Doroty Ramzi [inaudible] there was one night in Cambridge,
I don't know where the fuck it was.
And then there was one out in Worcester.
Um,
all of that shit.
All that shit has been Kelly's Kelly's something pub.
And uh,
in north Redding,
I think it was on reading,
it was in Redding,
Massachusetts.
The first place I have a bond.
Um,
and where I met a buddy of mine,
Wayne Previti.
Um,
so whatever he's been doing that all week.
there's always been people in the crowd,
like some older people remember in this fucking room is laughing off.
Fuck,
I'm getting all stuffed up here.
God Damn it.
Um,
oh yeah.
Memories do those rooms down in Rhode Island sky.
John Perrotto I think is coming out tonight.
It was like the fucking,
the first straight shooter I met.
He's always,
what's going on brother John Peralta?
What's going on,
Bro?
Listen,
I got a room down here.
I can pay about 25 bucks.
What do you say,
brothers?
You'd come up,
you knock it out.
You're always doing a good job,
right?
You'd be like,
yeah,
John,
anything for you man,
I need the money.
I appreciate it.
Oh,
I brought it up.
She,
when you get down there,
he's like a former wrestler.
What's going on brother John Browder?
Um,
he used to work for bill downs and they used to call him bill,
no money down because you'd get there and he was struggling.
He was one of these guys was make a lot of money in the fucking,
the big eighties.
And then,
uh,
him and his partner split and his partner fucked him over.
And uh,
so he was,
he was a good guy,
but he's always scraping,
trying to scrape the money together.
And uh,
you know,
he'd fucked you owe you 50 bucks,
you'd have to drive to his house.
And he'd be like,
Hey,
big guy.
Big Guy.
All right,
I can give you like eight bucks.
I can give you eight.
He give you like $8 of it,
like you'd have to go to his house like nine times to collect 30 bucks.
It's fucking hilarious.
Um,
it wasn't at the time,
but now when I look back,
all of that shit was,
yeah,
big guy,
big guy.
I hit and I'll tell you,
And um,
and one time Greg Fitzsimmons was coming up from New York and he was closing one
of this guys rooms,
right?
And he had already heard the rumors that he didn't pay.
So he fucking goes on.
I think I already told the story of what I would tell it again.
He fucking goes on right before he goes on stage for his final set,
he says to downs,
he said,
aw man.
He goes,
you know what?
I forgot my watch mate.
Can I borrow your watch so I don't go over and you know,
Bill down.
It's like,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Big Guy,
big guy.
Don't worry about ego.
Big Guy.
Right?
And it gives it to him.
It was a really nice fucking watch.
So Greg goes up,
crushes,
finishes his set and immediately just goes right out the door,
jumps in his car and fucking drives back to New York.
So the next day,
bill downs calls a month and he goes,
uh,
he goes,
hey,
big guy,
big guy.
He goes,
yeah,
you left man.
He goes,
you got my watch.
And Greg goes,
yeah,
you got my check.
And there was a pause.
And then bill goes,
oh,
big guy.
So he waited to the fucking thing cleared and then he sent him his watch back
was fucking brilliant.
The kind of shit that I never would've thought to fucking do.
Um,
so anyways,
all of those stories have been coming back.
You know,
some of the guys who've been coming in town hanging and with just sitting there
laughing and talking about all these fucking rooms we used to play in.
And um,
oh my God,
you'd go in there and they'd be like a Bruins game on and a,
this is back,
you know,
there's still playing in the garden.
Neely was playing and all of that shit.
So,
you know,
they were the fucking second coming to the big bad Bruins.
Every game was exciting.
It was,
it was,
it was the early 90.
So the second golden age of hockey,
and she was just coming to a close where,
um,
you know,
it was the perfect balance of physical play and just unbelievable golf scores.
Every team was in playing the trap.
The players weren't fucking gigantic the way they are today.
It was before the clutch and grab era.
And,
um,
it was just awesome hockey.
So every fucking game it seemed was great.
A couple of great rushes and unbelievable goal and a couple of fights.
It was just,
it was the fucking greatest.
And,
um,
we'd go in and do standup when these pubs and that people would have no idea
there was a show diverse.
Always remember there was always supposed to be a sign and the guy never hung it
up and they'd just be some fucking awful
ray,
a fucking radio shack microphone or something and they would just cut the sound
off on,
on the game,
right as people at the bar will gone.
Joe,
what the fuck I'm going to be like,
hey everybody,
welcome.
Welcome to the first,
uh,
the first comedy night here at a sucker punch bar and fucking South Boston.
And we're going to try to do this every week and be able to shut the fuck up.
And he just sitting there hanging your head going,
all right,
here we go.
Gotta take my lumps.
And um,
but it was great like the comradery that you had with the other comics that you
started out with doing those fucking hell rooms as they were called.
Um,
it was funny.
It was how you went up and you learned how to,
how to keep your composure standing in front of a room full of people that hated
you has been the only way to learn how to do that unless you are blessed is to
stand in front of a room full of people that hate you over and over and over
again throughout the first.
I don't know how many,
you know,
until you fucking move up and you don't have to do them anymore.
And,
um,
it's an unbelievable skill to be able to,
to do well in,
in a hotel room.
Like I haven't had to do those,
fortunately for a while.
And I can guarantee you that if you put me up in one and nobody knew who I was,
I would,
I would fucking eat my dick.
I have wood because they wouldn't give a fuck.
And my skills to get them to,
to give a fuck would,
would not be sharp like they need to be.
So,
uh,
you know,
he's fucking theater gigs.
If they're there,
lay ups,
you know,
they're not like,
they're not like they used to be,
you know.
Anyway.
So,
um,
let's get to some of the questions here for the week or Billy headquartered
here.
All right.
What do you MMP content.
All right,
Guy Guy who forgets his girlfriend's name.
How high can you fly?
You never,
never reach those guys that in my fucking Skype pilot.
Oh,
I know.
Cause I've had Sirius radio all week.
Um,
all right.
Tons of replies and tweets about the email last week from the guy who forgot the
girl's name.
He met this chick.
He fucking really liked her.
He couldn't remember his fucking name,
her name and a pay waited too long to ask her.
So now he doesn't know what to do.
So here's what they say.
They,
somebody said,
ask her to spell it.
I'll do it.
That's like,
that's not even a 50,
50 roll of the dice.
How do you spell your name?
Jen.
J.
E.
N.
O.
There's not two ads.
How do you spell her?
Hey,
how do I spell your name again?
A m.
Y.
A Mi.
If she has an easy fucking name,
it's going to,
you know,
in a regular Naf last name.
You Know Amy Clark Clark would have the,
and there's another one.
Ask her for her email address.
Um,
signed back up for Facebook.
That's what I said.
Wait til she texts you and say,
I lost all my numbers.
Who is this?
Oh,
that has potential.
Ask her straight up.
Straight up now to ask her straight up and tell her that her name never mattered
because it was his soul and that he was in love with her soul is what you should
say
it straight up.
And tell her her name never mattered because it was her soul that I can feel
every woman listening to this cringing on that one.
That's like a,
a somebody,
you know,
must have taken the stars out of the skies and put them in your fucking eyeballs
because a,
I'm seeing the big dip up.
Whatever the fuck you say.
What are those dumb lines?
Uh Huh.
Those stupid fucking one liners that never work.
Hey,
did you ever go to the Grand Canyon because your cleavage is fucking off the
hook with the stars in your eyes.
I can never remember shit like that.
Like I can never remember street jokes.
I always laugh my ass off to guys go on a barn.
I can never fucking remember it the same way.
I can't remember.
It has gotta be one of those one line as I can remember.
MMM.
Hey,
you haven't must be missing an angel cause uh,
so I'd like to fuck the hell out of you.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how they go.
I don't fucking,
I don't remember.
Hey,
you know what,
I'm looking at you and I,
I,
I dunno.
I like you and I,
I want to be on you.
Okay?
The fuck would I say to a woman I've been fucking tied up for so goddamn long.
What in God's name would I say to a woman if I walked into a bar?
Hey look,
I know I'm old.
I know I've talked to stop walking away.
I just say it in a nicer way.
Hey,
how you doing,
sweetie?
Do you have a,
you wouldn't happen to have dad issues.
I want to do this.
This is a good youtube video.
The worst fuck it pickup lines.
You could come up with it.
You just have a fuck and you make yourself up and you just hit on women in the
worst fucking way,
you know?
And you want a friend of yours and then you have like a point.
You have a point system.
All right?
Okay.
If they get up and walk away,
that's one point.
Whoever gets the most points wins.
All right?
And the whole thing is to be funny.
You're not actually trying to pick them up.
All right,
so is the gate all right?
If they get up and walk away,
that's one point.
If they throw a drink in your face,
that's too,
if they slap you,
that's for
now.
That's three or whatever.
Here's the point system.
I mean you should get a roll of the eyes.
Maybe roll of the eyes is one point.
All right.
Um,
if she does like that fucking like get it done,
whatever the fuck they say when they make that face in their mouth gets shaped
all weird.
Like,
like they're going to get,
when they make that fucking look,
we'll say,
maybe that's worth a full point,
right?
And then however you will have it is fuck you want to work it all right?
And then you get enough via doing it and then draft kings.com we'll fucking let
get bet on it.
All right.
Pick 10 knuckleheads without going the salary cap.
Right.
Okay.
Somebody last week,
one $30.
Um,
I can't tell you that.
That is a fun thing to fucking do.
We used to do that shit back in the day when we would just walk up and like,
it was almost like this weird thing.
It was sort of a defeatist thing,
but in a way it got you to get over your fear of approaching women.
And a,
the key is to just go up to women you don't give a shit about and just do that
and just practice,
just getting over,
like feeling stupid and just say stupid shit.
Oh my God.
We used to do that down in daisy Buchanan is back in the day.
What the fuck were we doing down there?
No one in the,
one night we hung out.
Right.
Um,
this guy came in,
Johnny Hickey who made this movie called oxymorons that you should check it out
on Netflix.
Matt's really good fucking underground movie that a lot of people,
uh,
you know,
don't know about.
And a comedian,
I know a patty Ross fucking crushed it in that movie.
But he came by and um,
so we,
we hung out with him that night.
We went to one of those fucking meat market dance clubs.
Right.
Just hilarious.
It was a bunch of fucking old guys.
We were all laughing.
They stuck us in this VIP room and uh,
it was in the back,
totally secluded.
There's all these gorgeous young women and fucking people,
good looking guys,
all dancing and shit.
And we go through this rat maze to go to this VIP area of where God knows how
many fucking orgies ever happened.
And we're just sitting in there,
you know,
three married guys,
two guys in like a Aa.
So the ladies come in,
right?
The fucking waitresses,
you know,
dressed all hot.
Then they'd look in as they come in,
like,
Hey,
I'm looking at us.
And I think one of us ordered a seven up
by the end.
One of them was just sitting down talking to us about comedy.
It was fucking pathetic.
But anyways,
first he had left his phone over at the Wilbur theater and they had locked the
place up.
So I called one of the guys in.
Fortunately,
he was still in there settling up some shit.
So I ran over there to help them.
Okay.
And as we're walking back to the club,
I was going,
Jesus Christ,
for as he look at these women here,
my God,
I don't remember Boston having as many good looking women,
right?
Fucking thick thighs.
Clydesdales walking down the street,
just crushing it,
right?
And I says,
I sent it to verse,
we were walking into the club and these,
these two girls sitting on a curb crying,
he goes,
yeah,
that beautiful.
He goes,
you know,
most of them are,
most of them are crying.
And I go,
that's because they're trying to find love and these clubs fucking dopes.
Right?
And we just started fucking dying laughing because you looking around and all of
these,
uh,
the type of guys that go in there,
you know what I mean?
Those guys who actually take selfies.
And actually I take selfies in front of sports things,
but you know,
the duck lip guys and who do the fucking peace side,
you know what I mean?
And get their eyebrows shape.
What,
what are you,
what are you going in there for?
Like you,
you're gonna find you're gonna find a meaningful relationship.
Yeah.
You're not gonna find anybody in there.
You got to get to join like a fucking like volleyball,
volleyball or softball league.
You know?
That's where you're going to find a good guy.
Right?
Granted,
it's probably gonna have some,
some sort of a drinking problem.
I actually,
you know what?
I don't know that I'd go to a softball league to meet a guy.
I do that to meet a woman.
Like if a woman was playing like softball or some shit,
you know what I mean?
Jesus.
I just pictured some girl just fucking grunting.
When she throw raw,
it's just making the throw from third.
I have the worst ideas.
Don't fucking listen to me,
whatever,
but I can tell you right now,
you're not going to find your way for husband and one of those fucking,
uh,
dance clubs.
Are you?
Yeah.
If you're going to tab in your shoes off,
crying in the gutter and you need,
deserve it,
enough,
deserve it.
Unless you keep going back and forth trying to find it.
All right.
Let me read a couple of these fucking things here.
Let's get outta here.
Let's get out of this.
All right,
here we go.
The classic everybody,
stamps.com you do whatever it takes to make sure your business runs efficiently.
Don't yet,
but constant trips to the post office can get in the wave of a productive day.
With stamps.com you'll be able to spend less
time@thepostofficeandmoretimegrowingyourgoddamnbusinessstamps.com makes mailing
and shipping Eg eg eight take it easy.
Use Your own computer and printer and print official US postage for any letter,
any package stamps.com does all the thinking for you with the digital scale.
It will calculate the exact postage needed.
It helps you decide the best class of mail based on your needs joint over
500,000 small businesses that you stamps.com and never go to the post office
again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my,
uh,
my posters that I sent out.
They sell after the show.
After the show.
I'll be standing there with my posters.
Would you like to buy one a?
Right now?
I'm use my last name per bur for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
For Christ's sake,
what are you waiting for?
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the page,
the homepage and type in Bar B,
u r r Bravo Uniform Romeo,
Romeo over this stamps.com enter into prayer.
I just fucking started over my own Goddamn name.
All right,
the last one.
Legal Zoom.
We're Gunna zoom,
zoom,
zoom.
Awesome.
We're gonna legal,
legal,
legal zoom.
Come on,
give it a try.
We're Gunna show you just why we're gonna teach you to get an LLC.
Um,
are you the next world famous entrepreneur?
Are you,
you're fucking dope.
Or maybe you don't care about fame.
You just want to help people whenever your motivation is.
If you're an innovator,
it's easy to launch your dream this month with legal zoom.
Incorporate or form an LLC to start your business.
Register your trademark to protect your products and services.
Apply for patent to secure your invention.
Over the past decade,
legal zoom has helped more than a million people,
just like you turn their ideas into reality.
So what's what's special about this month?
You might be asking,
maybe you're not asking,
maybe I'm asking questions for you and it's getting annoying.
For a limited time.
You can get special savings on any trademark copyright,
our provincial provisional patent application,
go to legalzoom.com today to get started.
They can help you if you have a great idea,
but you're not sure where to begin since they're not a law firm.
You can get advice from a legal legal zones network of independent attorneys,
attorneys in most states.
That means you can get the guidance you need to get,
uh,
your great idea off the ground.
Don't forget to enter burpee.
You are,
are in the referral box at checkout this month for your special discount,
legalzoom.com promo code burpee.
You are,
our legal help is here.
All right.
So anyways,
I did mention in that I believe,
oh,
I don't believe that.
Um,
I did mention at one point that the um,
uh,
shit,
what the fuck went?
Oh yeah,
that'd been going out after every show.
You know,
signing the posters and shaking hands and everything and I,
everybody's been fucking great.
I do have to tell you though,
this,
some people out there that don't know how to shake a hand and I'm not talking
about the lip lymph,
the dead fish handshake.
I'm not talking about the lobster claw.
Like you're helping me out of a carriage on prom night.
I'm not talking about either one of those.
I'm talking about the guy when he goes to shake hands,
he fucking brings his hand way out to his side,
pauses and then just fucking like 90 miles an hour.
Grabs your hand,
almost like fucking rip show Rahmati is socket.
It's like the fucking handshake version of Charles Barkley's golf swing where it
goes up to the top and it stops for a second and then fucking follows through
the every show.
There's like one guy who does that and I'm hoping I'm talking to somebody right
now who does that.
Don't do that.
You shake somebody's hand,
you look them in the eye,
you reach out.
Okay,
point a to point B,
farm handshake and then you let go.
That's it.
You know,
bring your fucking handout.
It tried to fucking gang,
grab it and then grab it at a weird fucking angle and then pull it towards you
as you shake it.
You're fucking dope.
I swear to God,
I'm going to say something tonight.
If somebody does that to be like,
dude,
who,
what?
What is,
what is your like fucking
that's like those guys that just,
they can't handle like a like,
oh I'm going to touch another guy.
Oh I got to get all tensed up,
can yank in the goddamn thing.
Drives me up the fucking wall.
And I actually debated
bringing that up to you and a guys,
cause God knows somebody who's going to do it on purpose.
I think they're funny.
Oh,
I'm trolling you whenever the fuck these fucking kids do nowadays,
uh,
whatever it is worth it.
If I can just get one person
to just stop doing that,
just fucking relax.
Point A to point B from handshake.
You let go.
And it's over.
All right.
There you go.
You can try and get your business off the ground,
walking around,
fucking yanking people's arms out of their sockets.
Like Jam Band Guy Did to that fucking love dude on,
on the,
on the uh,
the Cavaliers.
By the way.
I think the Cavaliers are going to win the championship and I can say that,
cause I've sorta overheard what's been going on.
Now I'm picking the Cavaliers to win the NBA Championship and I'm picking the
ducks to win the Stanley Cup.
But I can say that having spent the last fucking 10 days underground on the
ground as far as being a sports fan,
I haven't watched any games.
I got nothing.
You know,
I'm,
I'm working the entire time.
The Games are on the early games,
in late games.
And then at night when I come home,
my parents are asleep in front of the TV watching Fox News.
Okay.
Um,
so you know,
there you go.
Um,
Oh hey,
did anybody see that fucking in Waco,
Texas,
those rival bike gigs,
like some 20 on 20 gun fight in like nine guys died.
And it was all these innocent people around there.
I got to tell you,
I got to admit something as a white guy,
when I saw the picture afterwards of how they had them all rounded up and the
cops were standing there with their backs to him.
Finally,
Swami,
he said like,
I hope I can find it on Facebook was just talking about how,
because they're white.
They just had them sitting there,
these people in,
and then it was one of those things,
I don't give a fuck how much of a Douche you are.
You have to agree with it.
It was fucking ridiculous.
These guys just had a 20 on 20 fucking gun battle.
Okay,
all right.
In a God damn.
Yeah,
the fucking mall area.
When a restaurant,
there's all these innocent people,
right,
and what do they do?
They just have them sitting there doing,
a couple of them were sitting there on this smart phones texting.
There was all these stab stabbings and all kinds of shit that happens.
Shut.
Do those who fucking black guys forget it.
It probably would've shut all of them,
or at least most of them got to admit man and was,
it was pretty fucked up.
Somebody wrote something,
you know,
they're cops,
they're white.
Those are their fucking police force.
They're fine.
And uh,
I dunno,
I don't think as a white dude,
I could fucking argue that God knows I'm argumentative,
but it was pretty fucking ridiculous that you could shoot up a damn restaurant.
Nine people die and then afterwards you guys are all huddled in a corner just
sort of sitting there,
you know,
looking like you're waiting for a bus to take you back to your fourth,
whatever you're doing,
you're a biker gang.
Um,
I don't know if anybody can find that.
I would love to retweet it.
I,
I'm one of those old guy is how old I am.
Actually.
I love Facebook.
I fucking love it,
man.
I love that.
They just skimmed the fucking news for me and I don't have to try and find it.
I liked that young people hate it.
Like,
boom,
it good.
You still on Facebook?
Yes,
I am.
Please.
You and your DJ music goes somewhere else.
I love that.
I ruined your fund here by being the old guy on it.
Where the fuck is it?
Scrolling up.
This is the only thing.
He can't find it after a while,
you know?
Um,
what the fuck is this?
Some asleep Nate laying next to a python.
MMM,
hang on.
Hang on,
hang on,
hang on.
Yeah.
Uh,
fuck.
I can't find it.
When are you going to do and I'm gonna fucking
Goddamn fucking cold now.
God Damn it bill,
but a dope.
Alright,
let's just read these things here for the rest of the rest of our time here on
the podcast.
All right,
back breaking jobs,
back breaking jobs.
A bill.
I didn't get a chance to listen to Thursday's full plot podcasts,
but in the beginning I heard you ask,
are there any backbreaking jobs left?
Sing as you live in southern California and fly helicopters.
I thought you might be interested in learning about hot shot crews if you
weren't familiar with them.
Uh,
they were formed in southern California in the 1940s to fight wildfires.
That job was about is backbreaking as it gets.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I've seen that on the phone.
I've seen that on a new,
seen it on the news,
um,
where they,
uh,
you know,
they got like the full fucking fireman outfit on and they're just marching up a
hill with a fire hose.
Like it's nothing like it's nothing.
And then they start a fire around where they're at to establish a perimeter.
Yeah.
You know,
I actually,
I knew there was backbreaking jobs,
I just couldn't think of any.
So now we're going to learn about some,
uh,
he goes,
I'm not gonna explain it in detail,
but hot shots or some gnarly people and they put out the majority of large fires
in the western United States.
It's a really cool,
unique old school job.
Um,
I did it for many years based out of northern California and had a blast,
but it was so fucking hard and it,
it trashed my body.
I'm still fighting fires,
but I ain't fucking with the hot shot lifestyle anymore.
I don't think there were many jobs in United States involving more intense
manual labor.
Then fighting fire on a hot shot crew.
You should check out smoke jumpers to another really cool backbreaking job.
Uh,
there's some real cool videos and information online about what those folks do.
If you get time to look it up,
I think you'll dig it.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
you're supposed to do that for me.
You just got everybody all fucking interest in now.
You gave him homework.
He gave me homework.
All right,
I'll fucking line.
Yeah,
I'll say I'll look it up.
That all depends.
If I even remember,
uh,
he says,
shit,
Bro.
Get your pilot's license and maybe someday you'll be buckets of water on fires
for some hot shots.
A smoke jumpers.
Thanks Billy.
And Go fuck is,
ah,
fuck Tom Brady's balls.
He said,
dude,
there's no fucking way I would do that.
Okay.
I'm a weekend warrior.
I'm going to go flying into smoking shit.
Get all freaked out,
you know,
spatial,
disoriented,
whatever the fuck it is.
I can't see the horizon,
um,
from a lady
from a lady bill.
I love your stuff.
Uh,
but were you this angry over that dog murdering psycho Vick being allowed back
in the NFL?
Um,
no,
because he fucking spent two years in Leavenworth prison,
you know,
uh,
Brady's suspension is certainly one of the organizations,
lesser offenses.
What do you mean the Patriots?
What else do we have?
What else?
Suspension.
Do we have spy gate 15 fucking years ago.
What do we have before that?
We got nothing.
We got one fucking suspension in a 50 years of a franchise.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Will you this angry over that dog murdering cycle?
Yeah.
I have a pit bull.
What the fuck do you think?
I thought it was disgusting.
And then they gave him two years.
11 worth 11 words.
Fucking prison.
There's murderers and rapists in there.
The guy's career.
He was never the same.
Never came back as a foe.
A healthy start or anything.
It completely fucked his whole life up.
What else?
More.
More did you want done to Michael Vick?
Okay,
well that was an easy one.
Okay.
No,
I was,
I was absolutely thrilled.
I wasn't upset.
I was,
I wasn't angry at Michael.
Victor was like,
I was,
I was sick over it.
Okay.
I was sick.
Fucking confused how anybody could fucking do that.
And then,
you know,
I don't know,
two years sitting in a fucking jail cell.
Leavenworth prison.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would say that he paid the fucking price,
you know,
that's gonna follow him for the rest of his fucking life.
And you know,
I mean,
I don't what,
what else did you want done to the guy?
I know you're one of those psycho dog lovers,
right?
Fucking drown him and shoot him in the fucking head.
You know,
one of those people.
All Right,
dad is a junk food addict.
I hate that by the way.
Like when you fucking flip out over some fucking bullshit like that and this
when he's going to bring up something else,
you know?
Well,
what about the fucking moon coming closer to the earth?
Isn't that more important?
It's like,
yeah,
but you know,
we weren't talking about that.
Where are we?
Well,
actually,
no,
that's a bad example because that would be fucking something in the present if
that was actually happening.
Right.
This was something that happened.
The guy got caught,
he went to jail,
he lost,
he lost career and spent two years in Leavenworth prison.
I thought it was done.
I am one of those people though after that.
And he went to jail for two fucking years.
I am one of those peoples that dance goes all right,
you paid the price.
I'm not one of those guys who just goes,
fuck you for fucking ever.
You know,
you know these people who you want to solve shit,
but they punish people and then they never take them off punishment and never
give him a chance to fucking try to put their life back together.
Um,
all right,
dad is a junk food addict.
All right.
Hey,
Billie Barry balls,
um,
every week on the podcast.
So he would talk about the salt sugar fat cycle is as addictive as any drug and
I 100% agree.
Um,
I don't know if it's as addictive as heroin.
Obviously,
God knows I didn't do a study,
but I know it's,
it's the same kind of thing.
He goes,
I'm trying to make,
um,
I'm trying to make a,
what am I,
where am I trying to make good dietary decisions in my own life,
but I'm worried about my dad.
Every time I visited home,
I seem plowing through shells of Oreos,
steaks,
pasta,
and an unthinkable amount of soda.
He's in his sixties type one diabetic and overweight,
yet he does nothing to improve his died.
Every time I tried to get him to eat something healthy or even keep the lettuce
and tomato on the cheeseburger,
he gives me a response you'd expect from an alcoholic who's been cut off from
the bar.
He goes,
I've tried to eat healthy.
Oh,
Jesus Christ,
my brothers fucking over here,
practice in his clarinet.
I,
I'm fucking from the most crazy family over.
He gives me a response.
You expect from an alcoholic who's been cut off at the bar.
I've tried to eat healthy in front of him.
I've voiced my concerns.
I've even made fun of him,
but eventually he eats what he wants.
He's the guy who raised as a girl,
raised me,
and he's playing for the end.
He's paying for the groceries.
So it's hard to sway him,
especially when he's so stuck in his ways.
What can I do to get them to eat healthy once in a while?
Uh,
Jesus,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you.
That's a diff,
let me shut the door here.
When my brother plays the horn here.
Hang on a sec.
Right?
Unbelievable.
That's the family I come from though.
You know,
and he's a fucking sick ass guitar player.
And then you just got to move on to the next thing.
All right,
now I'm going to fucking go after the clarinet.
I don't hate,
you know,
it's your fucking life.
Whatever you want to do.
Um,
what was the question?
what can I do to get them to eat healthy once in a while?
Write him a letter.
All right.
I think he's,
he's one of those guys.
You can't come at them like that.
Just tell talent,
you know,
give us some stats and just tell him he's going to fucking die and you don't
want them to die because you love him.
I would do that,
you know,
and then it's up to him.
Okay.
And then you can feel good if something bad happens that you actually,
you know,
yeah.
Do you fucking tried tried to get him to go for walks or something cause that's
not gonna end.
Well man,
I,
I had a friend who was a diabetic and he's no longer,
he's no longer around man.
It's a fucking brutal thing.
But uh,
yeah,
it's hard to help someone that doesn't want to help themselves.
So I,
whenever I'm,
you know,
I've had people like that in my life and I always went with the letter and now
he's found the letter was a great way because they can read it when they want to
sit down and read it.
They're by themselves.
They're not,
you're not looking at them when they're doing it.
So they can actually maybe have their guard down a little bit and take it in.
Because it sounds like,
you know,
your dad is defensive or he's set in his ways and all of that shit.
And um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Um,
that's fucking statutes.
It's,
it sucks.
It definitely just,
that's a very difficult thing to deal.
You know,
I've had people have problems with boots.
I should fucking talk 10 day,
God Damn Bender.
Right.
Um,
but uh,
okay.
Yeah,
I go with the letter man.
I go with the letter and good luck to you because they got to be receptive to
it.
Um,
you know,
fuck,
what are you going to do?
Yeah.
That brings back some bad memories.
Um,
all right,
let's end on a positive note though.
Uh,
I just got to,
I just got a tweet from the one man thrill ride.
We got a picture back in the dressing room and this fucking guy's hilarious.
Um,
okay.
What did she say?
Awesome mean bill burr last night,
new material was gold.
Joe Barr,
Nick Paul Versey crushed it to great night.
Yeah,
man,
it was a fucking sick night.
Sick night here.
And before,
you know,
it was next time I talked,
this run's going to be over and I'll have a cold and who,
you know what?
It was fucking worth it.
I want to thank everybody who's come out to the shows.
Everybody bought the posters,
even came by and said hello.
Even those people don't know how to shake hands.
Thank you for coming out.
I don't think I'll ever do this again.
Um,
you know,
19 shows at one fucking place.
It was a hell of a run.
I did it.
And if somebody breaks the record,
God bless you.
It's all for you and you know it's yours.
Do
I don't want it.
I don't want to try to come back.
Thanks again to,
uh,
let me say this right.
Uh,
Jessie's custom design.com for that unbelievable goalie masks that you made for
me.
Thank you Jessie.
I swear to God,
I don't have that thing forever.
They'll just go right write my office and the most prominent place I can find.
And uh,
thanks to the thrill ride for coming down.
A good luck with your big audition coming up.
I know you're going to crush it.
And,
um,
good luck to raw Roger Goodell.
You know,
I know he's got a tough case coming up where he's on one side of it and he's
judging it.
A good luck to you,
Roger.
I hope you were able to somehow,
you know,
really bring the hammer down,
really bring the hammer down to two gangs for fucking knocking out your fiance
and a in an elevator,
but for games,
for letting a cunt hair of air out of a ball and a 38 point loss.
You know,
why don't you look at ESPN study where they show it was a disadvantage for fuck
sakes.
Whatever.
What are you going to do?
All right,
that's it.
You know,
not to say that what Michael did was Vic did with lether.
Uh,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday when I'm just checking.